hello I'm Sami Akana today I'll be
giving you an overview of the associate
cloud engineer track that is part of a
career readiness program from Google
cloud in today's presentation we'll
start with an introduction to Google and
Google cloud we'll see why businesses
are moving to Google cloud platform I'll
briefly discuss the increasing skills
gap in the cloud first world and how you
can help your students build career
skills by leveraging Google clouds
associate cloud engineer track I'll
provide an overview and review the
benefits of this program and timelines
I'll also share what your
responsibilities would be as a faculty
leader I'll discuss how Google cloud
will assist faculty and students in
completing this program Coursera and
quick lab setup will be presented next
and I'll conclude with the next steps
for you to take I'm sure most of you are
aware that Google started in 1998 in a
small garage today Google has more than
70 offices across 50 countries for the
past 20 years Google has been working
hard to organize the world's information
and make it universally accessible and
useful we've created products such as
search Android Chrome Maps Play YouTube
Gmail and drive all now with over a
billion users however it's not just a
scale that's interesting about these
products what's interesting is the
infrastructure Google's core technology
infrastructure that we had to build in
order to achieve our mission this
infrastructure of powers all our
products Google cloud platform is a
suite of cloud computing services that
runs on the same infrastructure used by
Google internally for its end-user
products so why our business is moving
to Google cloud platform
when making this transition most
companies are not just looking at how
they can move their existing computing
to the cloud or to reduce costs and
increase reliability and security they
are also hoping to create new
opportunities Google cloud has been
placed in the leaders quadrant by
Gartner in 2018 Forrester also
recognizes Google as a leader in key
areas of cloud computing more than 1.3
trillion dollars in IT spending will be
directly or indirectly affected by the
shift to cloud by 2022 adoption of cloud
native applications will double by 2020
this accelerated move towards cloud has
created a tremendous demand for
qualified professionals who are
proficient and cloud technologies the
growth in cloud adoption has resulted in
a corresponding increase in the need for
workers killed in Flour technologies so
are your students cloud ready to bridge
the skills gap we've built an enterprise
ready curriculum leading up to industry
recognized certification
leaders print through the associate
cloud engineer track to empower your
students to succeed in cloud related
careers